one's shooting raps on a movie props
usually get packed up for the next film
auctioned off for charity or given to a
museum but sometimes actors just take
the props from the set for themselves
with no one the wiser
whether for sentimental reasons or
because they feel they're acting
deserves a more tangible reward than a
paycheck there are plenty of famous
actors who have admitted to nicking some
valuable and not so valuable props when
shooting was finished here are some of
the props that I just stole from the
sets of their movies lock it up
after the final film of the Hunger Games
franchise Mockingjay part 2 was released
a few of the main actors revealed that
they had taken some props home over the
years considering josh hutcherson played
the perpetually romantic pizza was he
admitted to stealing is actually quite
sweet I took home and catching fire like
the locket that Peeta gives - Katniss
there's like the three pictures in it I
took that home meanwhile Jennifer
Lawrence took home some pieces of a
character's amazing outfits I have the
leather jacket the leather hunting
jacket and my leather hunting boots
unlike his co-stars liam hemsworth
claims he didn't take part in any
thievery so what did he leave the set
with lots of memories and good
friendships hammer home while liam might
be surprisingly good hearted when it
comes to that stealing things from set
his brother certainly isn't as innocent
Chris Hemsworth has kept a memento of
every single time he's been called upon
to play the God of Thunder and the
Marvel Cinematic Universe do you steal a
hammer at least a hammer all of you -
how many how much do you have there for
one of those hammers is on permanent
display in well his bathroom next to the
toilet if you need some assistance with
that feels like a like a toilet paper
holder like a very expensive it is now
Bella Swan a jewelry thief Kristen
Stewart was only 17 years old while
filming the first Twilight movie and 22
in the final film Breaking Dawn Part 2
was released to theaters while a vampire
loved Robert Pattinson and the rest of
the cast reportedly don't seem to have
many fond memories of filming Stewart
appears to have more of a soft spot for
the franchise
she told People magazine that she kept
some jewelry that Bella Swan wears in
the film to better remember director
Catherine Hardwicke and co-star Robert
Pattinson Stewart submitted
the Rings the Rings are really important
to me only conventional desires if
there's any movie that depends on its
props it would probably have to be Fifty
Shades of Grey
the franchise became a box-office smash
inmate Dakota Johnson and Jamie Dornan
almost as wealthy and famous as the
carrots as they played but according to
Marie Claire Johnson took something else
home besides her massive paycheck one of
the floggers from Christian Grey's
secret room she made sure to specify
that it's just gathering dust in her
garage which seems like a very different
use for the item than Christian Grey
would have for it live long and pilfer
Simon Pegg has been pretty open about
his humble nerdy beginnings and at this
point he's definitely made it as a geeky
lad living out his dream jobs he
appeared in 2009 Star Trek reboot and
reprised the role for the sequel star
trek into darkness
according to female first peg finally
accomplished a longtime childhood goal
by keeping a Starfleet badge while
filming the sequel this mustache Lee
insignia despite tight security Pegg
admitted that he was able to slip the
badge into his bag without anyone
noticing
it's kind of cool secretly Slytherin
Daniel Radcliffe was only 11 years old
when he started filming Harry Potter and
the Sorcerer's Stone and he continued to
star in the franchise for nearly 10
years considering he spent most of his
childhood providing childhood memories
for other kids it makes sense that
Radcliffe would once a souvenir of his
time spent on sets even if he had to
steal one that souvenir turned out to be
a couple of pairs of glasses the Harry
Potter wears one from the first movie
and one from the Deathly Hallows Part 1
it's a sweet reminder of the time he
spent on set but you'd think he would
have gone with a wand right